folks let's talk hybrid tractor tires
these are grown in popularity these are
a combination Tire right you take an R1
and R3 and R4 so a Turf Tire an AG tire
and Industrial Tire the best properties
all those are rolled into one we have
the versaturf over here the R14 here
pretty similar different manufacturers
making them the versatariffs are going
to be available for the sub compacts and
some small compact tractors the r14s are
going to have a lot of sizes for all the
different tires in the compact tractor
range some manufacturers are seeing the
light like Summit these are a premium
tire at a premium price point they come
standard on the summit tx25 if you're
buying a new tractor see if you can get
these tires on there or if you need a
new set of tires find an industrial tire
shop like a place that works on semis or
off-road equipment that kind of thing
they can probably find these tires for
you you can get the Carlisle versaturfs
on Amazon they're not going to tear up
your lawn but if you need to go off-road
as well and the dirt in the woods even
on snow and ice they're going to perform
way better than most other tires on the
market these tires provide optimal
traction tread life and versatility